welcome to this video this is the second
video about round form of Tata steel
2013. yesterday
um I presented um the game aronian
against Anand one of the
yeah Best in games probably of anand's
Korea winning quickly and then brilliant
style against um the board number three
iron
um but this round four was a very
spectacular round with some very
interesting games so I decided to make
um
second video going through the other
games
um and um I have a closer look at them
I'll start um with them
in comparison um probably least
interesting game this is some Anish giri
against peterleko can go through this
really quickly we had a nimso Indian
and Giro played Queen C2 which is um
known as the classical line it
um gives check
pretty um unusual move order it gives
white to the bishop pair without
um damaging the pawn structure but it
loses time with the queen and this line
that Lego chooses here was taking on C4
is a very modern line designed to win
more time on the queen now white has
made one two three Queen moves already
and hasn't done anything yet for his
kingside development
preparing castling and Blackwell
will probably gain another Tempo with
Bishop A6
this is um popular recently for black
Bishop G5 Bishop A6 Queen A4
and here black has a choice he can go
Queen D7 as a Lego plate or you can also
play C5 which is also an interesting way
to play allowing this um
somewhat damaged Pawn structure with
black hats ideas on for counter play
in the game that's oops sorry
so sometimes I just hit this button
going forward five moves Queen D7 was
played which is fairly logical winning
another Tempo on the queen and so if
white would take it would um speed up
black development even further but it's
questionable if white has a better move
where should the queen go so we took it
and um
nothing much was happening
the only slightly interesting moment was
exactly here where I just uh expected
black to take on F1
what he didn't do
um he he played the interesting Bishop
to B7
um not um getting rid of the bishop pair
but Bishop B7 controls the light squares
this is probably the idea and you get um
the bishop back anyway with attacking
the G5 Bishop we will see what I'm
talking about like this and black may
actually managed to
with the Hub of G5
to
exchange this bishop
and now important move A6 to control B5
yeah now black is perfectly safe the
only thing he needs to be aware of is
the square C6 that no piece lines there
and it's really just a big exchange now
coming and um
yeah you don't need to be rated 2700 to
check to draw this game
um really E5
this really was played I can't believe
this check this is some some glitch and
um and on on ICC E5 certainly wasn't
played
um just the draw here G3 would be normal
and it's simply that equal
all right so um this was more like
um yeah getting it complete this game
wasn't so interesting
um
so let's have a look at Nakamura against
kayaking next
foreign
which was really predictable kayaking is
um
has got a relatively narrow um opening
repertoire
from such a world-class player he
place the nimzoo and the Queen's Indian
and doesn't really vary that much
it's 92 year white has a wide range of
of opportunities we get a fairly um
standard looking position but Knight B3
was
was um a bit um a bit unusual from at
least for my
for my eye yeah we have um this typical
hanging Pawn formation
um at least
we have it now I just forward a couple
of moves white will at some point
capture on D5 and then we get these two
so-called hanging pawns and the white
has a pretty interesting setup against
those pawns involving the Knight on B3
which allows Queen A5 or Knight A5 and
this is annoying because those pieces
are somewhat loose on the queen side and
we see
in the following moves yeah this is also
interesting exchange on F6 and now it
tends to reroute the Knight to E3 to put
pressure on D5 not on D6
we'll see what what I'm talking about
Queen A5
yeah also utilizing the square
black um yeah black cannot really
exchange the Knight on A5 would be
really super annoying so Queen D7 taking
this this piece and now I dropped back
to E3 and now we see that white has some
real pressure on D5 it's black um plays
D4 he would make this Pawn backward and
also give away the C4 Square so it's not
so easy for black probably he's not in
in big trouble but it's a slightly
annoying pressure on these pawns
um and one idea in this position would
be this move C4 which sometimes looks a
bit strange but um
that's a concrete idea Knight D4 and
then my idea would be to play Bishop to
G5
trying to damage the pawn structure or
provoke right in doing moves that he
really doesn't want to do like F4 for
instance for example
um I'm not 100 sure I probably would
prefer white anyway but it's um it's um
it's an idea at least
um
the game he played D4 which is uh a move
that you certainly need to be a very
cautious with as it concedes
um yeah some squares to White
we had the exchange Here and Now
Nakamura didn't even go to C4 he played
net F5 which is even stronger attacking
this this piece and threatening to um
yeah to take their winning a piece yes
the queen also needs to watch um the A6
slide and it's surprisingly difficult to
coordinate the black's pieces here
to avoid the loss of a pawn in fact in
the game he immediately gave a pawn with
um this Rook move and it's very
difficult to to Really avoid this
um I actually don't know how to do it
um watch has numerous ways to um to
increase and he has got Rook C4 and and
similar
um maybe this um
deform move wasn't so wasn't so great at
the end this seems like a tricky
position for black
okay he went in the game Rook to E8 and
now after this you need to check with a
rook as the queen must watch the Knight
and now simply C5 is gone
whitest one upon check
now covering the e-pawn and um yeah
white has has certainly a pretty
substantial Advantage but it's not um
completely trivial as black as um
putting some pressure on the C2 Pawn he
maybe um can activate the queen it's um
probably not um
the clear-cut win but white is certainly
much better
we see that Nakamura
the dated the position and
try to get some pressure on D4 yeah this
is uh debatable as it gives black a pass
Pawn but of course it also gives white
this four against three majority trying
to advance it and the queen is a
notoriously bad blockader but um in fact
it's not so terrible here
um the thing is in this position
black is um
controlling the C file and always will
have a little bit of card to play as it
turned out
don't want to analyze this so deeply
it's um they are much are many
Alternatives along the way
I want to get to one very instructive
point
yeah white um open this up and now
Black's King is is exposed
yeah you cannot
go uh D3 because of Queen G7 and
this kind of things coming so black cam
needs to um
pin The Rook
and now we get the queen a queen end
game
with white have an extra Pawn but very
important is to note that in queen ant
games
um of course extra pawns are very nice
but in Queen end games very important is
to have a fight once past spawn quite
often um the side with being being born
down but having an a great um pass Pawn
Advanced um it's it's even better and we
see in the game that kayaking has this
chance here with his d-pawn
and why it has six to pawn he's got
three against two here and two against
one on the queen side but there's no
pass Pawn and um this means that white
always needs to be cautious at this
point is pretty quick in advancing
um we see that Nakamura is entering here
with the queen and now this is very
important and the move that I want to
show it's not 100 clear that this is
mathematically in terms of a computer
the correct move but it is a very good
human move activating here the point
further and advancing it to get counter
play you need to push the past Pawn this
is um absolutely essential and in fact I
believe if you look at this um Nakamura
now grafted and here in fact he
immediately stumbled and allowed to draw
but
um the the funny thing is if you take it
now here and give this to the computer
it gives it gives white a pretty pretty
big plus but um it's uh it's very very
difficult to see how um how wide should
win this game actually he's got all
these extra pawns but black is playing
uh just D2 or queen C2 and D2 and tries
to promote and how do you um how do you
prevent this I'm not sure and I would
need much more time to analyze if this
is really a win Nakamura in the
interview the brief interview after the
game also stated he wasn't 100 sure if
it was winning or not
um maybe it is but it's it's difficult I
mean black cam just goes somewhere and
white cannot exchange queens or
something and it's simply the problem of
this Pawn maybe it is a draw anyway I'm
not I'm not sure
um you cannot trust the computer it
tells you plus two but uh this just
means their extra and it doesn't see an
immediate draw if the only thing that
the computer is doing for 30 moves is
checking and makes no progress then this
plus two is worthless
um I'm not sure my feeling is it might
be a drum
in the game um he played F5 actually now
it's really a mathematical draw sd2
there's the immediate thread and now
white needs to um give a Perpetual which
which she did so
um yeah he made he made it relatively
easy for black but maybe it was the draw
anyway it's not not 100 sure I would
need to invest much more time to figure
this out you cannot trust the comp you
need to go much deeper I didn't have the
time my suspicion is drop but
I wouldn't bet the better house on it
that I don't own actually okay so um
this was a pretty pretty interesting
draw and what else did we have we have
Corona against even sokolov which I
could um go through um briefly
this was a ruler pass
and of course the club is one of the the
biggest expert of 1841e5 from the black
side he also wrote the book The ruler
pass Revisited which is uh heavily
recommended for any E5 player as it
contains so many interesting ideas
zocalov is a man to watch for E4 E5 as
black
um he plays all kinds of lines and him
he comes up with the the archangels
variation the Archangel variation
um pretty I'm pretty unsure about the
the name in in English actually I think
it's it's called really the arch angel
but uh it is named after the Russian
regions are kangels it doesn't have
anything to do with angels
um okay well Bishop B7
and um
Karana just goes for the conservative
line D3 there are many sharp options
here C3 rookie one but just D3 and I
mentioned in a previous video that black
needs to be cautious of putting a bishop
on B7 if white is uh putting up this uh
this Pawn formation yeah now we have
exactly that but um of course it's a
difference in the other line the bishop
was only set where Bishop B7 is a
problem here
matches to to get this bishop out
um so if we continue a couple of moves
um I would much prefer white in this
position he looks um more active and um
a problem is this bishop
black has um yeah no real option other
than than trading and we'll see what
happens
right threatened on H6
in the long run black needs to trade
this as uh D4 was was threatened and
then you would have a really terrible
Bishop on A7 so um you need to take this
and now we have this structure with the
half openf file
and the possibilities of this
maybe not exactly this route H4 is
covered but
I don't like this position so much
blacker doesn't have a real role for
this B7 bishop and white has the f file
open I don't really like it
um
I think um sokolov was a bit um
because I'm a bit unfortunate with this
opening Choice here it looks already a
bit tricky for black he
um
try to um
stay solid in the center but right now I
was able to play D4 even and now he has
a big Center and black has no real
counter play I think Carolina did a very
good job here I'm not so sure
um where the where the mistake was in
the opening
um I'm not sure maybe somewhere around
here like needs to do something else
but um the games didn't look too great
to me this bishop this this line is a
bit out of fashion people usually go
Bishop C5 nowadays and to keep the
options open for this C8 Bishop yeah
well in the game after 97 um karwana got
the great position simply the the center
the B3 Pawn that it was just just bad
this is a tactical trick
black gets the piece back now but Dwight
has of course a great Center
and um just went went for the spawnant
and won it okay black tries to struggle
with with tactics but now comes the
mentioned uh other idea the Knight on F5
and this is always an issue if you have
played H6 you cannot really get rid of
such a Knight without H6 well G6 would
weaken the position but at least it
wouldn't give away the H6 spawn and here
um black is just toast D6 is also
hanging so um he struggled on for a bit
but for a player of um
Carolina's abilities it was pretty easy
I think to win this these six is so weak
and um
here
why just a couple of Pawns up I think
two pawns it still has has the activity
with eform
that the MTM
here regrouped the pieces to to get a
king side attack here that's just Rook
H5 and Rook coming on the H file and
black cannot cannot defend against this
yeah I think um
probably the the problem of the root of
all the problems was somewhere in the
opening where black really um got into a
passive position and I'm really not sure
I dislike this whole setup a bit with
Bishop B7 and um
committing this bishop early to this to
this to this Square
like doesn't seem to have an adequate
counter play here
not not 100 sure about the theory but it
doesn't look good
um
so um what else well there we had also
uh vanville against Evan Lami the Dutch
duel both players certainly looking for
a point I would say you need to need to
win somewhere and the the best chances
against them
yeah against the compatriots in this
case okay so um the Trump
price from fanville here obviously
um has prepared a couple of off-beat
lines at least offbeat for his
repertoire
um to surprise the opponents Lami went
for C5 of course black has a big big
Choice here C5 is an interesting sharp
option white captured and played D5
which
um
that's the idea to make some use um of
blacks support we can structure we'll
see what happens Queen B6 black
immediately tries to get play on the
dark squares which have been weakened of
course Queen C1
F5 and C4 yeah white it's um basically
just intending Knight C3 and maybe
getting a knight to F4 and keep Black's
pawns um yeah somewhat inflexible
playing against the Bishops to not allow
them too much activity especially C8
Bishop is an issue for black as it
always we we can advance love moves
like this
this bishop always bite some Granite
against this F5 pawn and this is
actually something that black is not
easy um yeah black cannot easily avoid
if you wouldn't play F5 if you had the
pawn back on F6 then the G7 Bishop is
looking extremely stupid so
um white tries to um yeah well give up
the bishop here but inflict some
structural damage
this is also why he goes uh with the
Knight to F4 the sun has this idea and
also having a look at the sixth Quarter
Square that black cannot easily play E6
yeah we have a couple more moves another
interesting decision uh to take on C3
I would be reluctant to do that simply I
like I love my Bishops but um probably
uh it's not so bad
the ideas also yeah just open the G file
and damage white structure a bit in
return so C4 is um as a weakness of
course he now continued with E6 covering
this of course it was hanging so this
was something that black needed to take
care of anyway
and now we have um taking
and the four white opens up the position
and now Knight G5 and now we we actually
already um have one critical moment of
this game and I think La me went wrong
here
right um has the
simple thread Knight to F7 and of course
black needs to react in some way and he
now came up with uh with an exchange
sacrifice which probably fought short
um what he could do is um just cover F7
with let's say here
and after taking on on H7 if white would
do that I mean it's it's the
it's the move um that is most principled
after you went Knight G5 then black can
try move like um
Rook to a rook here
um intending let's say 9g5 Rook G7 and
then C4 is still hanging
black would have come to play anyway
with the open files on the king side all
this
can be used for the Rooks
so um I think this was an option what he
did was
something else an interesting idea but
I'm not sure that is really working he
played this and now the Rook is saying
nt6 is saying and he decided to
sacrifice the exchange by capturing on
C4 yeah but white grabbed it no not much
not much else to do queen E2 the
question is to um does black have enough
yam
um probably not if you look at the game
um
I I don't really see um an obvious
Improvement after a couple of moves
but
um the computer also um
doesn't like it it's um probably you
don't have enough activity on the on the
king side and the structural Advantage
is not so great for black I mean it's
got one pawn and a compact structure but
Dwight isn't bad anyway and he's got a
pretty good Bishop
so um probably yeah this is not not
really a correct sacrifice
attacking C5 and this is also a move you
don't really love to make yeah when
Billy is um
really playing the the toughest moves he
just captures the pawn don't need to be
afraid yeah the H file is not so
dangerous and the pawn is important
securing yourself two connected passes
so if your Queens are off you will win
automatically and
um I think you did a good job here
not allowing too much Whitehead always
some advantage
and yeah the problem is white um even as
The Taking Chances so
um you could wonder if World War why is
black even I'm attempting to exchange
Queens but the problem is wider easily
um could get the king side attack or not
this is nonsense attack on the king yeah
not on the king side let's say Rook B1
yeah probably yes wouldn't have offered
the queen trade but um
this is um pretty pretty much over right
kick now advances and he pushes the
Pawns
yeah black has some
only this past pawn and white has two
connected ones so this is just too much
it's pretty pretty simple
technical task
yeah the other
G7 thread um decided
if if black would would take here
then white can take here and black has
no way to prevent Rook h8 it's probably
even even a fast medium
yeah so um let's uh have a look quickly
at at this point yeah probably here this
exchange like um
wasn't
um wasn't sufficient
I I really don't I don't think it's it's
enough it's um it's playable maybe but
uh it's it's not enough to get full
compensation and after white grab even
H7 it simply was too much in terms of
material
all right so um we had also the Chinese
duel Wang Hao against two yifon
and one how playing D4
and we get a nimso Indian
with E3 yeah in fact um we get the
absolute main line of the three
Rubinstein system with uh with A3 the
the classical Main Line back from the
50s nowadays
um people
um very often prefer
these structures the the cup of mine
the hydrated Bond positions
at 96 is the absolute classical line
from the 50s
A3 takes and now Queen C7 also DTX D4 as
possible I don't want to make a really
deep theoretical
review here
this would would take take ages they
have been
books written about this position with
uh yeah
tons of pages so Bishop B2 which looks a
bit funny I I must admit that looks a
bit funny to put the bishop here but in
the long run the bishop will get into
play
and this is um
simply a matter of time after
um for instance black captures on C4 at
some point then later with eform you can
activate the bishop and Frankly Speaking
it doesn't have another Square
E4 is not easy to to accomplish without
black committing first
um let's see what happens black plays
rookie 8. and this is a good interesting
plan we'll see
this was the idea getting E5 in and also
preparing this way to uh to get the
bishop developed
H3 yeah this pin is annoying Bishop G4
this this is why y prevents it and uh A6
Bishop A2
and uh E4 yeah they have been um lots of
Alternatives along the way I want to get
to uh to a critical position
um yeah and this is this is exactly now
um here
black played um a very natural looking
move
it should be six and um it's possible
that this is actually
um yeah mistake hard to believe really
but it seems that um white
gets uh gets some Advantage after this
um there were Alternatives and black
could even think about about this move
you need to be cautious with closing the
queen side because it potentially gives
white a very strong Center if you
imagine something like this bishop B1
and F3 and if black would need to take
white would have a real Pawn roller in
the center it's still what's interesting
I don't think it can be refuted um
immediately
um I would prefer white probably after
three but it was it was an alternative
and the thing is Bishop E6 um runs into
and into tactical problems maybe it's
still uh playable but um it gets tricky
for black we'll see what happens and the
the fun move is D5 and this is
interesting
um white opens up the position in a
tactical Manner and uh gives um his
Bishops um lots of possibilities she now
took with the Knight if um black would
take with the bishop white would play C
form and this was the idea look at this
the bishop formally
strangely positioned piece gets into
life and will inflict a damage on black
spawn structure if you would take have a
look at this
and here white has excellent play really
black spawn structure is a complete mess
and he's got ideas like this for example
or queen G4 check
Rook D7 something like this here black
is in some trouble white has great
compensation at least
and yeah this is why Bishop D5 is
probably um not so great and she played
95 and this um had this consequence C4
takes and now Knight takes and here we
see that this bishop as mentioned can
get strong and it is a strong piece now
white we'll get this back probably and
has an open position with the two
Bishops going down the body
um she decided to play C3 which is
probably
um a good idea to simplify the position
a bit
and get pieces off the board before
white puts even more pressure on the
king side so we had a couple of
exchanges
so at the end white has the far better
minor piece this Knight is simply not a
great not a great piece on E6 it doesn't
have a good um a good post where it is
securely placed one idea could be this
but it's really slow to get it on a
square where it is protected
but I don't think it helps too much
here on Black's defense is really a
thankless task
also slide weakness here and
um yeah what um slowly increase the
pressure
and it's hard to tell where really the
decisive mistake was must say
um if you um
look at this just a second I had some
something prepared um
currency form I think um around here
this was all pretty logical in defense
like was simply um keeping his um sorry
her position together
but in time travel there were some
some accuracies
yeah in this position
um white actually just should take C5
what he did is um he played um King H2
and here we finally had the chance for
counter play which she didn't really
really grab
um
one move later actually which would be
six Bishop moves and now black she
probably should should try Knight to H
form
which um gets some play against you too
it um
could could continue this way
takes check takes and um no rookie form
and yeah black has some counter play at
least it's still probably um problematic
but um okay it is some play at least
that um a threatens Rook G6 and maybe
you have possibilities to somehow get
rid of the A3 Pawn like like the CM and
if you get rid of this Pawn then you
always have options to get some three
against four on the on the queen on the
king side and try to draw some look and
game or or whatever
let's say exchange one pair of groups
get rid of the bishop very difficult but
then you have drawing chances in the
game
she played The Rook C6 and after a
couple of more moves
um among how the um realized
disadvantage
especially after inform
then the Knight is completely um
completely out of out of places to go
were unavoidable yeah
um
I think the the most uh interesting
moment really was this D5 move which
opened up the position after this it was
really really difficult for black to to
defend this position really um
not the task um
he would like to perform against
some world-class player
all right and now we've got one game
left and this was probably
the most interesting one besides of
course the ironing game that I did
yesterday this is um yeah Magnus of
course the word number one playing
against
um Hare Krishna
um both players were on plus one so
important also for the overall standing
and um what opening do we get the ruler
pass the Joker piano on the scotch no
we get the poziani opening which is uh
probably never been played by 2700
player ever maybe someone can can look
this up but this is um really obscure
the ponciani
in fact it goes so far that
um even strong Grand Masters have label
this and as in as a bad or incorrect
opening it's probably shouldn't uh be
enabled um yeah so um
so badly it's probably equal but um
yeah it's a shame that high Krishna now
played Knight F6 which has a solid
reputation against C3 but the
theoretically testing move is actually
D5 and I would be very curious to see
what Magnus would have played
um he's obviously um knowing what he's
doing so he had some idea prepared
after D5
um white probably would play Queen A4
that's the main move and then black has
various ideas sacrificing material but
you can just play F6 this was actually
my recommendation in um in the E4 E5
repertoire Series where I played where I
made a dedicated video on the ponciani
um
actually never suspecting that it would
crop up on the board in some some high
level game all right Harry Krishna
played Knight F6 weave we probably will
never learn what Magnus had attended
after D5
um here D4 and now a surprise Hari
Krishna now went D5
um obviously you didn't expect this
opening so it was probably uh making
things up as he went along 94 is um the
main move here once you played the
Knight F6 and then D5 97 Knight E5 and
arguably this could be slightly better
for White Knight to six and then Queen
E2 this is how this is played but um
it's also nothing nothing spectacular
for white but certainly a position that
Magnuson probably was was comfortable
with with playing okay D5
and now Bishop B5
and uh
now we get a position which is very
similar to a position from from the
Italian game or the two knights
in fact um it is almost identical but
white has the extra move C3 this is
because in the Italian game are the two
knights he goes to Bishop C4 B5 if you
like I can I can put this on the board
what I'm talking about is
this line
memorize this position
this is the game
see it's identical but white has C3 as
an extra move and this is enough to get
right a little bit of an advantage we
will see why this is first you would
think okay C3 is this really useful but
it is we see why white takes down
everything very normal and uh C3 is a
useful move in this position because the
a thing that white would like to achieve
in an ideal world is to prevent black
from going C5 and get some peace on C5
therefore B4 is a fairly typical move
that white would like to make here
black played Knight to C5 back but just
to show what what I'm talking about if
black would take and now we'll play some
some passive move that didn't really fit
into the position let's say H6 okay it
doesn't make much sense but just to show
the idea what white would like to do is
to get something like before Knight B3
Bishop C5 and at the end have the Knight
on D4 or C5 against the stupid looking
Bishop on D7 and therefore C3 is a
useful move Magnus said in the interview
um after the game that he suspected
white would would have a slight
Advantage with the C3 being the extra
move and um he probably um
yeah it's right about that
it looks like um like a comfortable
position for wide where'd be Four
Knights back to B7 and and F4
yeah grabbing grabbing space white has
this idea of further advancing
um yeah here black had more than one one
IDM instead of A5 he also had the option
um of playing F C5
which um looked fairly logical to me
actually to get rid of this um this
double Pawn a possible continuation
could be taking
Knight takes and queen F3 attacking D5
and
um
after C6 white has the idea of going uh
C4
yeah I think um white is probably
slightly better really this uh
Pawn Duo here can can be uh dangerous
with F5 coming
and um
black is um is slightly worse probably
and the game A5 also makes sense get rid
of the the a pawn
but um now um we see that
um
magnus's um
really a creative player he's playing F5
and this is just uh just a good move if
you look at the alternative A3 the
normal looking move before was hanging
then have a look at this this is um
would be the
the simple way to to go about this and
probably the way that most players would
proceed
and here you probably have nothing
it's simply um that the queen was
distracted to the queen side so it can
cannot really help with any initiative
on the on the king side
and you've got this Rook of the board
um
probably it's around equal have a look
what happened he played F5
sacrificing this pawn and it's uh very
difficult to to not take it and probably
black should take it so um
this is what high Krishna did he just
grabbed the pawn
and now Queen G4 and now we see okay
white has sacrificed the pawn but he's
got something going on the on the king
side
a possible E6 is an idea and also uh F6
is an idea of course first the queen
needs to go probably to G3 to get out
out of the the pin here but um white has
those two pawns and they are dangerous
Bishop H6 of course is also a thread
so um what did Black do he played Bishop
T3 attacking The Rook oops this was what
I wanted to do taking the rook and um
another idea could have could have been
F6 cm to just stop the pawns but this
would lead to Knight E6 and after takes
takes
Bishop back E6 we get a position which
is actually fairly similar to the game
and in which um white has a big
compensation
um let's look what happened I think
Harry Krishna really did a good good job
of uh defending this bishop D3 whoops he
won attacking this
takes
so um yeah what is going on now A2 is
hanging and um yeah he grabbed it
probably
um Again The Right Move what else um is
there what if black um would play C5
this is an important important question
as
um if white would would capture on C5
then takes
takes C6 is very good for him A2 is
still hanging and there's Queen B6
coming it's a very unlucky diagonal here
um this is actually um good for black
so after oops sorry after C5 white
shouldn't take this is a mistake but he
has a strong move and this is E6
very important
the idea being after E6 if um
black captures now
then white has the cool move F6
putting the pawns to good use G6 only
move it was made on G7 and now white can
take and this is uh amazingly good for
white
at first I couldn't really um
I was a bit skeptical let's put it this
way because this Pawn is is dangerous of
course but it also looks like it can
easily get lost
but it doesn't seem to happen and
worldwide is also threatening is
something like this of course utilizing
um
this Pawn on F6 black is in big trouble
probably it's losing even
um so um C5 in this position wasn't an
option
and if this isn't an option what are you
playing yeah I think it did right he
took on A2 and with the idea of the
following
E6 with the main thread
and now simply F6
and um yeah now we see a really a really
great play coming
um white is not at all interested in in
taking this bishop of course
um at the moment D2 result saying a
fight would take now then black would
just capture here and this isn't really
um what uh what white was was intending
to do
he just played this move
and now have a look at Black's pieces
where should uh should this bishop go if
you would go to C8
white can simply grab the pawn and um
has gotten one point back and now has an
overwhelming position I mean just
this move from
would pile up on the C file on the C
Pawn also so Bishop to E8 it's it's a
better move you must protect it and now
white has sacrificed two points but look
at the huge bind that he has he has got
this amazing fall on E6 supported by F5
The Rook here has no Square the bishop
has no Square it cannot go anywhere
and how is black supposed to untangle
himself
um and try to
do something with the two pawns it's
really tricky and then Factor it seems
like white has exactly enough
compensation if you Analyze This a bit
um and then use the computer checking
out the various um continuations it
turns out that probably white has enough
compensation but he's not winning or or
close to even winning but um the problem
is that in a practical game this is just
a terrible to play You're just standing
yeah with them back to the wall and uh
and they need to defend all the time
with black so um I think for a long time
he did a really good job and
with with defending
but it's not not much fun of course
um here it was an alternative to capture
on F2 and um I'm not sure maybe um maybe
I would have done the following and lose
as well okay and my idea would be to um
to actually take here
and after capture
let's say here to go G6
because simply I I probably wouldn't
have the the patience to to stay put all
the time here is a question should white
play G4 or should he take
um in case of taking which is uh
probably interesting he can utilize the
the long diagonal but I think
just speaking for myself I probably
couldn't have standed to
um to to to stay put so long
um and this is probably
um yeah again compensation for white
but um it's hard to uh to put a definite
assessment on this it was an alternative
of at least for black he decided to to
just stay and not change so much about
the position however
in this position after Bishop C5
um
Bishop H5 which looks active you want to
make an active move I understand really
um probably it's not the best because
white
um wanted to go here anyway now has this
Knight D4 C6 IDM which um somehow yeah
it's quite annoying for for black
he needs to defend a V8 which he did
with the queen
and um
here
Queen A8
yeah here there was an alternative
in fact um there was one really cool
line I wanted to show sorry
here here I asked myself why not Knight
D4 and at first you think okay this is
easy right 94 and the Big Fork
in fact this is totally all clear white
can play Knight takes B5
Knight takes C3 and now the cool move E7
attacking The Rook intending to capture
it and winning the house so black black
needs to move it there's not much Choice
hook to F7 and then Knight C7 and funny
enough to attack the queen and this is
such a funny piece configuration that
white will promote it's it's unavoidable
and the best black can do is to capture
him
Bishop takes rookie takes Rook takes
here takes here
Robert E2 and now after Bishop to to G4
Rook D5 cd5 Rook C7 Bishop F5 we get to
a drawish end game
and it's it's possible that Carlson even
calculated this
um
in the in the game this was this move
Knight E4 in the game he went uh Queen
to E3 it's possible really he's capable
of doing such things and this puts the
pressure on keeps the pressure on black
um cannot really free himself Queen Aid
Knight deform and now he um tried to
relieve the pressure by exchanging with
this pseudo sacrifice
and 94
yeah 94 both Rooks
um looks very natural and the idea of
the sacrifice
um but it could be that um this was
actually a mistake
um black hat an alternative
um maybe quite surprising alternative
with a knight C4
which um just attacks the queen
and um yeah where should it go let's say
queen C3
and then Queen A7 this was uh the idea
the fun thing is that yeah this this
Rook is saying
and um
takes
and now look at this Rook it doesn't
have so many squares C5 is controlled
cannot go here can I go here
and in fact black even can spare one one
move like a rook A8 and then play Bishop
E8 trapping this Rook
um it should be Aid immediately if I
look at this
white can answer worth taking
and then the Ruckus
and a bit of a problem here but black
can can actually play and this is very
difficult to see beforehand you can play
Rook A8 and now this bishop E8 cannot
really be prevented
um The Rook is um in a way trapped here
white um doesn't have anything better
than sacrificing it back on C4 let's say
something like this
and then check even
this is uh possible oh no sorry look at
one of course look at one Rook a form
and we get get to an end game which is
certainly um should be okay for black of
course this is a complete um
yeah complete uh completely theoretical
uh possibility as there are humans
playing over the board and you need to
uh to assess this and this is very
difficult of course
I'm high Christian I had about four
minutes left and his idea obviously was
this 94 but after that um black is in
some trouble and this is
um becoming apparent rather quickly
Knight C6
takes King takes and now yeah white
regain the pawn so it's just one Pawn
now and D5 is very weak so white will
get this back and if you regain the two
pawns and you maintain this strong bind
on the position white will be uh it will
be substantially better it's still a
tricky position but um white has a
pretty big Advantage now
so maybe really Knight C4 but this is
really super difficult to see and all in
all you must say that the accountants
double a pawn sacrifice was was very
strong because it put black on such a
defensive position that it's um
basically a question of time when you
break down so so difficult to defend the
fun thing is the only play I would say I
was able to defend this as black as
cards on himself as he's such a great
defender okay King G3
after the check rookie 8
and um yeah and then H3 this is a very
very difficult a very very important not
so difficult maybe but very very
important move that often uh
players yeah don't appreciate um
so much those little moves that take
away squares it takes away the G4 square
and prepares to secure the King on H2 so
it's one of those little preparation
moves that um simply help white so much
in in winning the game without those
little moves you you would have a much
harder time to to actually convert this
we see that White's King is pretty safe
on H2 just a couple of moves later we
see that white puts pressure on the C
Pawn
it wins the deepon as mentioned
some regroupings
and um
it was certainly also an idea just to to
manage time control
seven also false now white is even a
pawn up he has won the whole Queen side
and now we see that King H2 how useful
this this flight Square was
yeah black um could could give a check
on F4 but it's just one check it uh
doesn't continue
um here and black is out of checks the
screen
controls are critical critical squares
so King H7
and now it's a matter of um a couple of
precise moves Queen F2 is a strong
little touch
it lets um the Knight hang but uh Queen
takes before would be answered by
queen to queen G3
and there's no defense to
the attack
for example if black would play Queen f8
to to cover there's a strong move Rook
F7 and um black um it's busted like this
check
yep intending
Queen to F7 and black black girl just
loses
a plate Rook G8 and a couple of moves
later
white um
nicely coordinated species check
s coming
but this is very nice not on the night
possibly you have even
going further towards the king
and here
in a completely lost position now Hari
Krishna made the final slight mistake
but okay it's lost anyway but this um
immediately
clinches the game cards now has a nice
tactical shot
if you like it you can
try to solve this not not too difficult
and the move is
uh Knight takes F6 and this is quite
quite nice uh he didn't
he didn't allow this to play out on the
body actually resigned with playing
Bishop C6 but Knight F6 would be the
move that that would come now with the
nice touch Queen takes D4 Checkmate Rook
takes f8 mate very very cube made
with the Knight
and The Rook taking away the squares and
of course yeah the queen is hanging and
it's a complete overload I mean why
should black go f8 needs to be covered
as well yeah so resigns was um
understandable in this position
yeah a great game I think by by Carlton
who really um
played there very creatively to
to to get the black into into a
difficult position
first the sacrificed here the the B Pawn
and then the a pawn and she got a great
bind on the position
where black was forced to defend
passively and this really led to uh led
to disaster with little time on the
clock it simply um
not feasible to just look at the
computer evaluation which is probably
around equal or
maybe even slightly better for black it
it's just not important the problem is
um just think of playing this is black
yeah sometimes you need to um just um
yeah switch switch to the board yeah
look at this from the defender and see
you've got everything oops you've got
everything sitting on the back Rank and
uh it's simply um a terrible
thing to imagine that you need to defend
this yeah it's a simple
simply um simply um a thankless Prospect
it doesn't uh
it's not any fun yeah okay I thought you
I hope you you liked the video and um
I'll be back with round five for
probably
um on Thursday and this will feature
um cards and against Ireland I think
avicially it's got white though and on
Carlton and we can look forward to that
yeah cheers and um yeah till tomorrow